uh
so hello everyone my name is peter my
monkov i apologize for this but i can't
get the google slide thing to work
properly so
uh we'll we'll make do and i also cannot
see anything here so
um but anyway so um i'm going to talk
about the circle circuit project
and uh and i also want to thank richard
before me actually
he set up the the stage for this quite
quite nicely
so i'll get straight to it and the first
order of business would be
is this working yes so to to motivate
sort of what are the problems that the
circuit is solving and
the high level picture is that the high
level picture is sort of summarized in
one sentence
which is that currently in industry
there is a big friction between
um essentially dev and ops
so the dev engineers the people who make
software and this is all about
distributed cloud applications and then
the ops people who have to install them
in companies and and make sure that they
that they work
there are many many many specific
practical problems that can
that can be mentioned but i've chosen a
couple that are sufficient to sort of
motivate the design of the circuit as a
whole
so uh let's let's look at some specific
problems um so the the first one that i
want to highlight
um actually can you hear me when i'm
speaking over here you can
speak up a little okay so the the the
first problem that uh
that i want to look at is perhaps you've
noticed that
cloud solutions meaning very complicated
cloud
very complicated distributed
applications that contain multiple
components
database ui services and so forth
uh they're never distributed uh really
in any kind of a standard fashion and
people typically distribute sort of
modular components like a sharded
database
or um or a ui you know service of some
sort
uh but you never get solutions you get
solutions from companies that give
give them to you as a software as a
service um
and they're uh we want to sort of uh
understand why this is the case
and i also want to convince you that
this is actually a huge huge problem
uh my my favorite example
of why it is a problem that we cannot
distribute
cloud solutions is uh let's say
monitoring systems so
most companies that have some scale
uh sooner or later run into this problem
where they have to build a monitoring
system
a monitoring system is a sort of generic
thing that basically
uh continuously monitors all the vitals
on all your machines and all your
all the other processes that are running
in your in your data center
and then it ships them over to a time
series database
and then usually you have some kind of a
non-trivial visualization framework
that can show you what's happening so
you can debug problems and so forth
now a lot of companies are building the
exact same
thing from scratch internally when they
hit the size of scale when they actually
need to have a system like this
and it turns out that this kind of
this kind of thing actually wastes a
huge amount of
human uh specifically ops engineering
effort
because it's not as simple as it as it
seems on the surface to just
uh tie a database to
to whatever is producing the data and to
um
some kind of a visualization service and
so actually
not only there's a huge cost paid
up front but this cost keeps on going uh
forward
and the fact that this is a such a such
a thing for human time has actually
created a whole
little ecosystem of startup companies
now
that are trying to in this particular
example provides
monitoring as a software as a service
but this is uh this is not an ideal
solution in many cases
because people usually don't want to
ship out
low level technical data sometimes for
security reasons outside
the real technical reason why people um
so i wanna i wanna point out two
technical reasons there might be many
more but these are
very important reasons why we're still
not able to ship
uh complicated cloud solutions
uh uh the way we can ship you know rpm
packages for
a single computer software the big
reasons are that
any distributed application needs to
know how to
start new processes especially if it's a
very complicated application
and they also need to be able to
provision or to negotiate the
provisioning of new hardware
if it's a fancy elastic database for
example
and none of this you you can't really
get an elastic database open source and
i'll qualify this statement more
carefully
um but the crux lies in the fact that a
cluster of computers
you know gives you all the general
computation um
facilities that you get from a single
computer but it also gives you two
new semantically different things you
can do which is
starting jobs and perhaps asking for
more
hardware which you don't have in the
single computer world
and as an artifact of history we just
don't have a
a way of allowing applications to to
require to request these things
programmatically in a standard way
and uh you know the other the other
place where
uh so the fact that we don't have these
things as a
as a standard sort of uh thing
uh also you know shows up like i said
you you can't actually truly
give me an elastic database because uh
because you know
whatever you give me there's no way you
can uh
you know how are you gonna ask me to
provision new hardware i mean this is
what elastic means
and in fact um i think that
in general when you give me a some kind
of a
finished distributed application
really i should be able to run it and
forget about it
except when the application needs to uh
need something done that it just cannot
do on its own like for example getting
new hardware
and i'll expand on this idea more but
for now essentially i want to focus on
the fact that these two things
so requesting job execution and
negotiating hardware
is something that if i'm the author of
open source
software like a database i couldn't
possibly write my open source database
in whether it's going to run in
everybody's data center no matter what
the configuration
is because i have no idea
how you start processes do you just
start them as a as a linux process or do
you actually have a complicated
job scheduling system like hadoop that
you would prefer to use and so forth
so there's no standard for this thing
and that's the big technical corrects
why people don't
uh for the most part these three goods
complicated
cloud solutions people do distribute
modular components like a sharded
database and so forth
and the way they overcome this problem
here is
they give you a documentation in english
which you have to manually read so this
is the ops team in your company they
have to read this
then they have to go on to puppet or
whatever else they use for
you know deploying and provisioning
software in their data center
and the bottom line is that you
basically force them into all this
manual work
there's many other uh technical uh
you know stumbling blocks but these are
the the big ones
so uh we're trying to propose a solution
here or at least
attempt a solution which which is not
meant to be backwards compatible
and it's a solution that only works for
people who are willing to use goal
so this is not a panacea for all
problems but
but it has some interesting ideas that
might be transferable to other places as
well
so if um if i'm going to
uh if i'm going to be proposing a
solution so let me
take another just uh just say a couple
more words here there are ways of course
to get around these problems like for
example
um you can you can build your
application such
it has a custom api point where
it requests these things and then the
ops people
who are actually deploying the software
can you know hook up to this api
but this is not a solution uh to the
problem that i really care for which is
to reduce
the human the human involvement when
it's
it shouldn't be really necessary uh
another another way people go around
this problem is that they say look i'm
building an application but you have to
use the following framework
to run it um and the issue with this is
that
uh i mean there's a bunch of obvious
issues like maybe i don't use
the framework that you have built your
application for
um especially because in
actually most of the frameworks that are
available out there that would give you
something like this
they solve a whole set of other problems
as well and they're too heavy weight
to to adopt them just because you want
to install my application
so i'm looking for some solution that
would be very easy and completely kind
of
a no-brainer to to to deploy with your
ongoing sort of
infrastructure so um and and so
basically
the the crux of this thing is we're
looking for some standard way
of allowing applications to request
these things programmatically
and and this always basically means one
thing
we have to have some universal format
for
expressing the application that i want
to ship
to whoever wants to use it and really
true isolation between application
development and ops
means that if i'm the application
developer i can write the application
one time
never touch it again and this
application can now run
on any spectrum of sort of different
data center setups
with minimal involvement of the ops
teams
and of course the other thing is that if
i'm going to be proposing
something like this i better make sure
that it can be adopted incrementally and
without disturbing
your current systems and so um
uh this kind of uh i mean we can leave
it at this but basically it has to be
able to like
you know perfectly fine run alongside
with other software that you might have
on your machines
and uh i and it really should be minimal
uh and and i'll make this very precise
further on
down okay this picture here is just to
give you
um an idea of how much exposure
a cloud application has to
to the to the human you know ops
engineers in a given company
so you know it's a silly picture but so
what i have here is is two hosts
um two machines that are running your
application whatever it might be
and just to give you uh just to show you
like a just a random list of things that
that ops people have to do for start for
start
uh you know they have to of course
configure the the application
and the thing is application kind of has
two kinds of configurations
one configuration has to do with
whatever the application actually is
doing this is something you always have
to do
but but every application every
application also has
infrastructure specific configuration if
you're starting a mysql server you
basically have to tell it you know
which parts to use and and and
you know if you're doing a zookeeper
thing then you have to tell all your
zookeeper instances essentially how to
find the other ones and so forth
uh and unfortunately every every open
source product out there
basically has a different uh sort of if
you will even just the file format of
how you configure things
and so it always requires manually
reading the documents and
and setting up the environment so it can
run
but but this is not the worst um the
worst thing is that
um a lot of application requires
straight up
manual effort so you know if if your
mysql shard dies
uh you know restarting restarting it
replicating it and recovering from this
thing
is basically a manual process you know
people have written a lot of scripts
that actually automate a lot of
you know parts of this manual process
but the process remains manual
and and this is a cost a human cause
that you pay forward
you know forever essentially and and
what i want to sort of
illustrate with this picture is there's
way too much exposure so the black stuff
is your up
there is way too much exposure to the
red stuff which is like human
involvement
on the upside and i want to avoid this
and this is of course
uh i'm going to repeat this this is what
has stimulated
uh some chunk of the software as a
service industry
and what's really ironic is that really
what they're providing is not software
in a lot of cases what they're providing
is essentially the human effort that
happens behind
the doors of their company uh
they're not actually because they're
using the same software that you would
actually use
and of course over time they try to get
better but for the most part
um they're not like giving a true
technological solution to the problem
so uh this uh this slide
here uh really summarizes what i think
a cloud application a finnish cloud
application should look like and behave
like
first of all i should be able to get any
new cloud application and deploy it with
a single click
just like you can deploy any application
on a single computer with a single click
if you think about let's say the new uh
the compiler tools and whatnot this is a
horrendously complicated
uh and complex uh complex is the correct
word
uh project uh and yet you can install it
with uh with a single click for the most
part and you can
just start using it you you can't say
the same thing for
um distributed applications
uh i think so the state of the world in
the single in the single sort of uh
computer is that you run the application
and and then you and then the user just
uses it there's no
there's no other for the most part
interaction uh in the in the distributed
world you can't quite have that because
like i said there are certain things
like physically provisioning hardware
that applications cannot do themselves
so the perfect shape and form of a
distributed application would be this
you should be able to deploy it with a
single click so to speak
the user and it's going to have some api
where the user
you know does whatever they do with the
application at the back of the
application there should be a very
narrow
interface uh which should be uh
essentially the same interface across
any kind of cloud application that you
might build using the framework that i'm
about to propose or
any framework that ends up being a
standard in the future
this interface between the application
and the ops team
should be very well defined very simple
and very
and very skinny so in particular the
kinds of things
that vary across different data center
setups
are sort of like for the most part
they're just three things
uh first of all networking okay we don't
know
ahead of time whether data centers
prefer to use tcp or something else to
connect between different
hosts and and currently the industry
always ships all these services that use
tcp
this is presumptuous but unfortunately
that's the state of affairs that we have
at the moment
but you actually have to ask the ops
team to tell you how to connect from one
machine to the other and what's the name
space of these machines and so forth the
other thing is like i said the job
execution
you don't know a priori how to start a
new
uh process uh on the remote machine and
and the final thing like i said is
hardware uh negotiation
for elastic services and so forth so the
aim of the pro
the project that i'm uh so the final
goal of this framework that i'm about to
describe to you
is to be able to enable you to write
applications
once that can then all be run
like this in a black box and and most
importantly no matter how many different
applications you write
uh the ops the ops team here only has to
learn one time how to how to provide
these functionalities to your
applications
and they're all going to work you know
fine
so let's uh go right ahead and uh
so i'm going to uncover the solution
concept in little pieces because there's
a lot of information
so i'm going to start with an overview
right
first of all the distribution format
that i postulate i want to use
in this case is i want to distribute
cloud applications in the form of a gold
source
now there there are deep semantic
reasons why this is a
really good choice but i'm also going to
tell you some sort of side practical
reasons which actually have little to do
uh with with the circuit itself but it's
good to have them in mind
um so the go languages is is so simple
and it's so well instrumented i mean the
library of the language is so
well instrumented with uh you know a
parser for for
for the language itself and so forth
that if you take
if you accept uh outside codes in go in
goal format
it's actually extremely easy to
instrument it in all kinds of ways
you know you can in fair like even
people who have no experience writing
grammars and parsers and whatnot
can easily for example instrument their
code to
uh they can hook up something like the
google dab or tracing system to all the
function calls that happen in the code
and
you know this is this is how flexible
the language is uh not to mention that
it's very easy to
uh you can look at what packages and
libraries an application is using and
you can
uh automatically substitute them with
your own you know if you cared
if you cared uh for this um
and and so on and so forth and of course
i think there is a bigger reason why
it might sound odd that in some cases
that you want to distribute applications
as source but when it comes to debugging
obviously this is quite helpful
so the framework that i'm going to uh
describe to you uh over the next slide
is going to give us the the promised
isolation between
ops and application
development and the final thing is
is that the application applications
that you're going to end up
building using the circuit are going to
uh
to essentially amount to compiling your
code
into a single a single executable that
that you know in fact the ops people are
going to compile
this but this happens one time and this
one executable can then be deployed in
the most
uh sloppy way meaning that you just run
it on on however many hosts you want to
run it
and this is a you know this is this is
what uh
people are already used to doing because
this is the format of most kind of
standard
um you know sort of distributed
applications
that you get nowadays and the the
just to give you an illusio a metaphor
of what really is happening
is you are actually compiling uh all the
infrastructure
that the cloud application needs into
this executable
so as far as the ops people are
concerned they just have to run it
without worrying
semantics consistency just run it on the
machines where you want to use it
and then this executable is is is
actually internally gone
going to organize the application in in
however you want it
you want it to behave with different
kinds of services and so forth
but to you this is all opaque to you as
the ops engineer this is all opaque
and you're just seeing the same process
running on a bunch of different machines
so now i'm going to um start uh slowly
digging into
into more details of what's really
happening here
so first i want to talk about this
concept which a lot of you have already
heard of this is
the concept of a single system image
this is a this is a vague
concept but um effectively what it means
is that
you you you want to provide a clean
interface
to the functionality of some hardware
below
and this clean interface is provided to
the application engineer so that they
can
write their codes and then
this code can run even under small
variations of of the
of the underlying hardware and and and
let me
sort of give you some examples uh just
to sort of get your brain thinking
on this so linux actually or any
operating system but linux for example
is a is a is a single system image
which gives you an interface between
your programs
and the hardware of of a single computer
uh and you know this is not to be taken
for granted like the simplest
example of a single system image um
and so uh and of course uh there are
many
there are many places in the software
stack where you can choose to
draw this line the interface between
applications and what's happening
underneath
so linux draw this line essentially at
the binary level
you can have an executable by doing sort
of uh
system calls they get captured by linux
and
and and all these binaries can can count
uh on having the posix systems calls
being implemented
um now um then you get into much more
sort of like uh
exotic and interesting different kinds
of single system image
a lot of people in the past have tried
to uh
to do something which is really the
classical example of a single system
image
which is they will they want to take a
cluster of machines
and with a lot of very complex software
they want to they want to make it look
like a single
linux machine so that you can
retroactively basically run anything
that you have a software uh written for
a single machine
these efforts have kind of failed for
the most part because they're trying to
do too much
uh in particular you know they actually
also try to conceal from you the fact
that some computers
die and this is very hard to do in fact
basically no one's really properly done
it and so a lot of these projects are
not used at all
um but uh the main thing is that they're
trying to do too much
sometimes you don't want your framework
to be too intelligent
um another one this very interesting
example is plan nine
i probably one or two people here even
know what plan nine is
but um it's worth so plan nine is
basically it's an operating system but
but really what it says
it's really just a protocol that says if
you have a cluster of machines
you know you can run whatever software
you want to run on them but i want
uh all the software that runs on these
machines to expose this functionality in
the form of uh
of a network file system and and the
single system image
uh is drawn here at the network level
meaning that
do whatever you want on the computers
make sure you always talk using the same
protocol
so really what you see your system your
cluster is just as a set
of file servers it's an odd example but
it is an example of a single system
image
now um then you have erlang
with its sort of runtime which is which
is which is a very interesting uh
case in this case um you you get like a
a set of again a cluster of hardware
presented to you
all the way at the programming at the
programming level
so you uh you basically uh
so the fact that you're running on
different hardware is kind of kind of
kind of concealed from you and you get
to get to take advantage of it by
like being able to spawn many different
threads communicate between them
and and and these are all sort of baked
into the language so it's so it's quite
type safe and easy to do this and and so
at the end of this line is basically um
so the circuit is is similar in many
ways to erlang
in the sense that uh it says we want to
give you a single system image of a
cluster
at the language level and uh obviously
uh if you're whenever you're picking a
language uh
to present the whole cluster at the
language level of course this language
has to have concurrency because
this is really the power that a cluster
gives you um
and the difference between uh erlang and
go circuit as we're going to see
is that um little ang the runtime of
erlang is uh i'm not a specialist there
so i don't want to like
make any hard claims but for the most
part is like a big monolithic thing that
you have to install
uh whereas the go circuit like i said
and you see
compiles directly into your application
so i can actually give you my
application and
you don't have to install otp runtime
before you can use it
uh nor do you have to learn how to use
the and
maintain the otp runtime and and so
the word minimal here so minimalist
single system image this is the word
that i've coined
to sit in front of this guy is
specifically um
emphasizing the fact that it's it's a
it's
again it's a single system image
interface to some hardware
but very explicitly i'm not solving any
problems whatsoever meaning any uh
algorithmic problems
i'm not trying to uh conceal failures of
machines or network from you
and so forth i'm i'm uh and
the this framework is simply abstracting
away
exactly the functionality as well as the
failure conditions
of a cluster to the programmer and then
it's your
business to to know how to deal with
them uh but it's
but it's quite easier to deal to deal
with these things when you have
when you have them presented to you in a
very clean semantic way
um so um i wanna i wanna say
why go was the language of choice um
and it's for very different reasons than
what richard was talking before but
but actually i think richard actually
mentioned this
uh this as well so um you know
most of you most of you already work in
companies that have big data centers and
um when you design essentially what's
going to be happening in your data
center you know
how does the information flow from one
service to another
you know do you even have feedback loose
between services and so forth
you start by thinking you know at high
level
uh what are going to be the services how
is the information going to flow and so
forth
uh so you're thinking in you know in
what's called the
the csp model so basically at the data
center level
you have independently sort of
independently running processes which
are the processes running on different
machines
and they are communicating sequentially
obviously through the tcp links
so at the data center level you're
already thinking in the csp model
and so uh my sort of short pitch here is
this
uh why switch the concurrency model
uh you know when you when you go from
across computers to inside you know and
there's a big cost if you
if you if you if you switch because uh
you know typically you design your
design your solution you know what the
information flow does and so forth
but when you sit down to program it's
usually in the asynchronous model
because this is the most popular model
currently in industry
i would guess um the cognitive
load of of sort of rephrasing your your
data flow you know logic into an
asynchronous thing
is it has tremendous costs which i'm you
know i'm not going to talk about them
now but
uh i'm always happy to to talk in detail
and answer questions
um and so so we chose the go language
first so essentially because
it has the csp model baked in we could
have chosen
erlang of course and then so the second
so the second reason why the go language
is the choice is because
industry seems to have to continuously
want an imperative language
especially when it comes down to
implementing low-level systems
things and remember the circuit doesn't
solve any sort of
special problems reliability and whatnot
which means that the circuit is very
much going to be used by people who are
implementing
um low level applications like you know
a locking service like zookeeper or
or or chubby in which case you really
want to be able to see
when a computer goes down so um
uh and and you know uh meaningful stack
traces uh
and you know is something so
in asynchronous programming you know if
you don't know the stack traces are
completely useless
uh because if you if you stop your
process you you just see the the main
uh event loop and it doesn't tell you
what's the state of your application
whereas in uh csp languages you actually
see that the threads of the the stacks
of the different threads
which usually have like very meaningful
uh they have like
a meaningful application uh they have an
application meaning that you can assign
to them and figure out where the bug is
and actually uh this is extremely
important because in my experience in
the past so
there's two kind of problems that can
happen in production right
one problem is um you know a process
dies and
you go there and you look at the stack
trace and okay so it's useful that we
actually have meaningful stack traces
and and but there's also these other
kinds of like what happens if a server
in production actually hangs but doesn't
die
this thing is nearly impossible to like
reproduce in the bug
unless unless you could i mean these
things happen rarely so the first time
it happens you really want to extract as
much information as you can and if you
didn't have the meaningful stack traces
it takes almost a year to to find some
evasive bugs so so bottom line
csp is very good for debugging and
tracing as well so
this is uh why we chose the go language
and so now abstractly i want to tell you
essentially what the architecture
of an application using the circuit
looks like so uh
you know you have you you have your uh
hosts here with their linux running on
them or
whatever other operating system you want
um and
um the the the application that you
write
you know think of it uh so it basically
uses
whatever the circuit is going to give to
it in terms of
um you know concurrency primitives and
so forth
um and your application is written in go
what the circuit does is it translates
this high-level convenient semantic sort
of source code that you write
into into very very basic uh
networking operations and you know
some spawn operations that sort of
correspond to when you want to start the
process somewhere
and these are all abstract operations
and they're very few of them they're
very simple
in terms of what they're supposed to do
so the whenever you give
your application to the to to a company
the ops team in this company all they
have to do is they have to write a
driver that just simply implements these
things
which is elementary to do in most cases
and you know if you have a very fancy uh
infrastructure maybe you have to put a
little bit of work
but you only have to do this once and so
and not only this but once you start
running your application
the only exposure that the ops team has
to your application
is is is is standardized like the
opsteam doesn't talk to your application
itself
the ops team just works with all the
instrumentation that comes with the
circuit
so they can monitor what's happening
without understanding what your
application does
in fact if you remember one thing from
this ops engineers should not have to
know the first thing
about what your application actually
does it's it's not their job okay
um and and the fact that they do is just
is just an inefficient thing
and and there's plenty of examples of
this in industry
um okay so this is like the abstract
high-level
architecture of what a circuit
application looks like
and now i want to start giving a
slightly more tangible feeling of what's
really going on here
so circuit programs so these are the
applications that you write
they really are nothing else but just a
a sort of a straight up go go you know
it's it's go code it's going to be
compiled by the go compiler
and the only thing is that so they they
they import the circuit as a package so
they see the circuit really just as a
as a package in the programming language
and this package gives them some
some new functionality where they can
exploit so the fact that they're running
on
on a cluster uh the circuit itself
uh is this you know fairly smart package
that
um that does all sorts of things and
somewhere in the circuit uh the circuit
says okay
i'm importing drivers for networking and
and
job but these drivers don't actually
exist anywhere in the circuit code
and so uh when uh when an ops engineer
takes your your program they actually
have to place
uh drivers you know wherever they have
to place them so that your application
can actually work
so this just gives you an idea literally
in in sort of tangible terms what is a
circuit application
and so again what a circuit uh
when you actually start running your
application what happens is
so your application here has all sorts
of it's straight up go code that you
know maybe creates multiple go routines
they talk amongst each other and so
forth uh you know the
the key thing that the circuit is going
to give you that you can actually like
start go
routines on on other machines but once
you start them they
linguistically they're no different than
then go routines
uh they're in the same process so
metaphorically speaking
uh you should be able to take any
program written in goal
and with minor boilerplate boilerplate
kind of
tweaks here and there you should be able
to make it distributed like in
in virtually no time um and so the
applications are
the application that you write it's it's
the same source code across
all instances but it's the source the
code is running at different
points in the code and the application
really is thinking that it's talking to
another go
routine in the same application but
really what's happening is
high level linguistic communication gets
gets converted into very low level very
simple networking operations to get
physically to the other side so
that's what the circuit is sort of like
in more concrete terms
and this slide um is just to give you a
sort of a sense of how complex uh
the kind of things that you can do with
the circuit are this is a project that's
going to be released in a few months
from now
but um this project essentially takes
your takes your data center and
um it becomes essentially it can run any
legacy
legacy linux process in a docker
container
that is instrumented in such a way that
uh
all the all the processes in all the
containers no matter
where they are physically they think
that they're part of the same linux
system because you can instrument your
docker container to
to give them the same view of the system
you know they can
they can see all the processes in the
same procfs
even though they're not actually on the
same system and so forth this is a
solution
that that's kind of like
makes legacy software be able to take
advantage of the circuit
and it's a whole distributed operating
system so the takeaway here is that
you have to think about the circuit as
an implementation technology
for what you really would use as a and
sort of user framework in your in your
company
you know just like c is just an
implementation technology for linux
and you know you use c here and there
outside of the kernel but not not so
much
so that's kind of where it sits in the
stack of things
and um let me just see how much time we
have
actually do we know can does anyone know
how much
time we have left in terms of minutes oh
zero okay
um well um you know i i can end
uh here um the next few slides were um
essentially just to give you a taste of
what it looks like to program for the
circuit
i'm just gonna they're like six or seven
slides so i'm just gonna swipe through
them
um but the main thing is uh for us just
so
for a start you take any legacy go
application if you just
include the circuit in it it already
becomes a circuit application
it will take advantage of all the
instrumentation that it has in it even
though you're not going to use
its other features and all circuit
applications
are compiled exactly like you would
compile a go application so you don't
actually have to learn anything new um
and
so i'm going to skip these slides uh
the the the the takeaway from these
slides is that um
the circuit really you it really gives
you like two or three functions from
this circuit package that you include
there's not
not much to learn really to be to be
perfectly honest really the only thing
sorry the only thing that that's that
you
basically have to learn is the circuit
gives you this new function spawn
which which runs a function
onto onto a destination that you pick
instead of in the current process
and and and that's the only thing you
have to learn because
uh i have gone through sort of a great
length to make sure that
you can basically pass the circuit a
function that's implementing your go
code
and using the reflection package of go
which as richard said is extremely good
i can do so much reflection that
your codes doesn't doesn't can be just
native go code you don't have to think
that
you don't have to worry that you
intended it to be run across different
machines and so forth
it just it just works um and
anyway so these are like the specific
uh examples i told you that the circuit
essentially translates between language
and networking operations
and and you know anyway it has
instrumentation and so forth
but i think the important thing was that
we actually managed to get through the
architecture which
tells you what you know what it actually
looks like um
yeah anyway are there questions
okay i mean you can always uh you know
shoot me an email
uh i'm sure you know i'm not hard to
find
but uh i am you know happy to answer
questions
thank you